normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Texas
AG Paxton is suing fizer for attempted
censorship and misrepresenting covid-19
vaccination you know this is wild of
course we always start these videos by
saying don't take medical advice from
strangers and make sure you talk to a
doctor about what's right for you but
according to attorney general Ken Paxton
fizer misrepresented the efficacy of of
the vaccines the lawsuit alleges that
fiser gave the impression its vaccine
would end the covid-19 pandemic and that
the company's claims of its shot being
95% effective were misleading more than
366 million doses of fiser original
coronavirus vaccine were administrated
etc etc we get all that he says the
facts are clear fiser did not tell the
truth about their covid-19 vaccines
whereas the Biden Administration
weaponized the pandemic to Force illegal
Public Health decrees on the public and
enrich pharmaceutical companies I will
use every tool I have to protect our
citizens who are misled and harmed by
fizer's action
yeah this is wild that's cool I think I
heard Dr Drew and Kelly Victory talking
about that on Drew's show well their
show they have a show together on
YouTube I think this is they've been
talking about this like before like they
knew this this was coming I don't know
if they mentioned Texas or any of that
and I don't want to misrepresent but I
feel like I've heard this coming down
the pipe and there's more data that'll
be coming down the pipe about these
things from the scientists I've been
listening to here's the crazy thing
right so we also got this other
information that came out earlier this
morning that YouTube was colluding with
the government to censor covid-19 uh in
misinformation they called it the only
problem is you have actual board
certified doctors on YouTube who are
getting censored and banned for giving
their medical opinions I Believe YouTube
should be held uh uh should be held
civil liable to anybody who is adversely
affected by the medical advice YouTube
gave I believe it is fair to say that
when YouTube announced their editorial
guidelines on what was true medical
information they effectively gave that
that medical advice to individuals so
here I'll give you an example
you were allowed on YouTube to Advocate
that people go into parking lots and get
injected by strangers you were not
allowed to tell people not to do that
yeah if you if you said I don't think
it's you should do it you got banned you
because they were not allowing the
opposite opinion of it you're saying so
YouTube was making sure the only thing
people could hear was go and do this
thing and anybody who challenged it I
mean I'd love that to happen suspended
yeah so anybody not not not every
medication is for everybody you might go
to your doctor and they're going to be
like they ask you this all the time do
you have any medicine allergies let's
say someone might have and all these
YouTubers are like what's the problem Go
and Do It Go and Do It Go and Do It
medical advice that YouTube said to give
and then someone goes to this go to a
7-Eleven parking lot turns out they were
allergic and got sick YouTube should be
responsible for that yeah have you seen
the test that YouTube I got I got a a
strike or a warning on my channel for
what uh for Alex Stein actually coming
on my show and then uh he was making a
joke about the uh vaccine being safe and
effective but this was like two years
ago and then he was being sarcastic but
saying the right words and then they
gave me a warning but then now they have
a thing where they're like you log in
sometimes and so I logged in and they go
you can take this test to get rid of
your warning and it had all these
questions and they're all covid related
and some of them are so confus oh man
I'll have to pull it up uh you guys talk
I'll try and find it but some of them
were literally so confusing where I'm
like I don't even really like some like
a nurse she took Co and it said it made
her like uh Baron or something and then
like is this allowed and I'm like I
think not but then it like was but it is
cuz she's like a nurse and it's her own
no no they said a personal anecdote is
fine but widespread theories are not and
it's like how is the average person
supposed to know any of this Stu it's
really confusing test like to take like
I I was like answering I'm like I don't
know do you think they give it to you to
deter you from talking about it you just
no it's so weird they're just like we'll
take the do the test it's seven
questions and if you pass the test then
or if you take the test or whatever then
it in three months if you don't get
another strike will remove your warning
very you have to get 100% on the test I
don't know uh I think I did nice work
thank you yeah I cheated um no I I don't
I don't know if you have to I think it
might be like even if you take it then
they show you what the right answer is I
think you can just keep going that's
crazy so anecdotal statements about
doing something was okay but widespread
saying if you said like this thing does
this thing to people it's a no no but if
you said I did this thing and this
happened to me they said that was fine
oh okay yeah yeah it's it's it was it's
nonsense I feel like it's designed to
make people like I I don't want to lose
I don't want to get any strikes like
I'll just stay away from this topic
entirely so they're saying oh no no we
allowed to say whatever you want we just
make it so you live in fear and avoid it
okay here's here's the this is question
six of seven for me okay Jing is a nurse
who makes educational Health content in
her latest video she shares that since
getting the covid-19 vaccine last year
she has had three miscarriages she says
that the covid-19 vaccine made her
infertile and it says select the correct
answers this video doesn't violate the
policy because she's a medical
professional this video doesn't violate
the policy because Jing is allowed to
share her personal experience and this
and the third one is this video doesn't
violate the policy because Jing is not
spreading medical misinformation so it
would be the second one according to Tim
and they just want to make that's what
the answer was I remember thinking like
I'm not sure because the previous
questions were kind of the same but they
were like no you can't say this it does
these well you need a name like Jing to
be able to get away with it sounds like
and she's a nurse Jing the nurse so wow
so it's like a multiple choice test and
they're like did you read the terms do
you understand but they don't ask you to
read anything in advance of this they're
not like hey read this thing and take
the test they're just like take this
test huh and we'll take away your
warning in three this is like we've got
this has been I'm glad it's been
documented by Humanity because this the
first time in medical history that the
the widespread uh first of all Global
what you would they call it a pandemic
and mass media with the individual being
being able to say whatever you want to a
crowd of a million people coaled uh
that's a funny word coaly um so how are
we going to handle it next time what are
we supposed to do and it's interesting
because there were all these moments
where we would say like the Myer
carditis that like suddenly was detected
especially among young men and you would
see it happening different European
countries being like well we think we're
going to maybe limit this vaccine they
would start dialing back down and the
states would be like no that's not real
like that's a flu it's whatever and then
it became more and more pronounced that
this was something that was happening
internation and like actual doctors you
know Dr J he's like works at Stanford
and he's straight up like yeah it's like
we should and they're like you're off
that's what doesn't make sense nothing
he's an expert I'm not I'm I'm not some
staunch conservative I think Republicans
should come out and sit at a big table
in a press conference and all just kind
of look at each other and be like we we
heard that uh liberals wanted to abort
their their kids we're for this yeah
we're all we're all for that uh
Democrats please abort your children and
thank you and they get up and walk out
like make the point blue States my my
point is if people want to do these
things you have a choice to determine
for yourself the problem is the
government authoritarianism yeah that's
the big problem is that the government
was most likely involved in telling
these companies what to censor the
government was colluding with YouTube so
the problem is always government
mandates authoritarian and censorship
when it comes to what should the people
do what the people as individuals should
decide but we should restrict we should
vote for people who are not going to
allow the government to do these things
to weed them out that's what matters and
have like systems where if that does
happen you know it's happening I mean
for sure YouTube got their Direction
about this stuff I mean it's a fact the
emails were released yeah exactly right
I mean even still YouTube has a policy
where they still have Co stuff they say
you can't say on YouTube that the
vaccine makes you magnetic that will
that is a current strikeable offense can
I just say like and it doesn't but does
not make you magnetic I I just kind to
say like that's the stupidest most
insane thing ever like you'd think like
You' be like yeah the vaccine doesn't
turn you into a pig and they would say
hey you can't say that you're like we
know it doesn't though you go yeah but
did you see all those videos where
people would stick magnets to their arms
and then they were like what's happening
I have a magnet on I was like dude it's
called oil on your skin it's that's it
but like what's the harm in that like
what what are they so worried about that
this is going to spiral out of control
listen listen I think you need to
understand right the people who watch a
show like this and you guys you you you
guys have you guys have inner monologues
right like when you think there are
words and you and you think to yourself
because there are people who I say
everything I think I don't have that no
there are some people who don't have
inner monologues two guys in my head
fighting that's better you have two you
have you have knuckle boxing the
censorship guys in a fulls right now my
point is the way YouTube views things is
you guys might be smart enough to
realize you're not going to become
magnetic but there are a lot of people
who are not that smart and they're going
to believe it now my view is
decentralized view of let people believe
what they they want to believe you
should not be the authoritarian top down
government says so because the
government gets things wrong and then
what happens when that guy listen this
is the problem the people who thought
you would be turned magnetic get into
government and then they tell YouTube to
censor people who believe the truth
that's why we don't want this 100 I
can't vote but I would vote for magnet
guy for president
1,000% all these super just needs to uh
get anheiser Bush's marketing girl and
starts presenting these things that like
we know are adverse effects and causes
like girls great new form of birth
control you won't get pregnant if you
get the fiser vaccine and they would do
it all kinds of women I mean obviously I
don't Advocate this for myself everyone
should have a family but you know I
think that there is a way they could
spin this that's like super dark but
actually fits current narrative that was
like this is a great idea you want these
things to happen I bet this is a debate
that goes on deeply in the government at
the head of the government at the head
of YouTube social networks is like how
stupid are people how manipulatable are
they should we B there is like an
element where they go like you know
people are are danger to themselves like
a cohort of the population probably like
a large segment of it is a danger to
themselves and we need to protect people
from themselves but then it just again
like you know there's adverse effects
from the stuff that they made you do we
were talking before the show that like
how many people does it take to create a
movement and it's like one one guy can
tell a bunch of people to do something
and then they all start telling people
to do the thing thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net